this video is sponsored by raycon having
grown up in ireland in the late 1990s
and early 2000s shows like yu-gi-oh
sailor moon and of course dragon ball
were widely available and accessible and
since then i've made it my mission to
catch up on all the most iconic stories
i missed growing up one piece jojo's
bizarre adventure hunter hunter and
attack on titan all brilliant stories in
their own rights but before i ever heard
of one piece and long before i ever
turned on that first episode of attack
on titan i heard whispers of a certain
show a story that was making noise
across the pond in the u.s one that cast
a shadow so large it managed to stretch
all the way from japan to my home
where i grew up we never got naruto so
let's see if i missed anything good
[Applause]
[Music]
i gotta say right off the bat picking
that first volume up off the shelf felt
terrific while i knew very little about
this story outside of the main
character's name naruto and that it's
for the most part about ninjas i was
without question acutely aware of one
inalienable fact that this was a beloved
franchise a story people massively
identified with and that it too has its
detractors sounded very much like dragon
ball to me so while picking that first
volume from my shelf i was filled with a
giddy enthusiasm i hadn't felt in years
finally after all this time i was
reading naruto and i
liked these opening chapters but i
didn't love them in fact i found them to
be a little unfocused if that makes
sense at all but don't worry this video
has a happy ending so sit tight for me
first impressions are important because
you only get one chance to make them in
that same vein the first paragraph of
your novel or the first chapter of your
manga in this case needs to perform a
host of different tricks not only to
hold your attention but to also
introduce you to the main character and
the wider world the story is set in and
of course there are different ways to go
about performing this narrative
somersault one piece took an approach
adequately representative of what would
later be recognized as odis style a
comprehensive and intensely powerful
character-driven story built on the back
of luffy's ambition hajime isa yama's
attack on titan 2 i think had a
near-perfect first impression on the
audience it was trying to reach
establishing its nail-biting premise the
motivations of the main characters and
giving us a taste of the wider world's
politically driven infrastructure i knew
i was in for an action-packed political
drama the likes of which i would never
forget so yeah first impressions are
important they're what dictate whether
or not many people will give a story
their attention in the future
particularly when it comes to manga
they're released one chapter at a time
after all it's not like a movie or a
book where the rest is right there for
you to digest and because of this fact
many manga begin their stories with a
much longer than average first chapter
to establish what they want and given
that naruto is still one of the most
successful mangas to ever be released i
was surprised by its introduction the
pacing felt fast almost too fast i will
say though that it did a decent job at
establishing the heartbeat of naruto's
journey with him effectively being the
outcast of his community armed only with
a burning desire to become the next
hokage i enjoyed that aspect of it
seeing naruto struggle with his lessons
felt appropriate hearing about his dream
felt intimate and the success he finds
at the end felt adequately cathartic for
a first chapter helped enormously by
kishimoto's fantastic artistic abilities
i mean that two-page spread of the
one-time screw-up naruto performing a
fantastic clone technique was given
pride of place and rightfully so i can
still picture that stunning shot right
now as i speak there's plenty i've taken
away from this first chapter that i
liked and it was certainly enough to
encourage more reading from me which i
mean is sort of the only job it has
right however along with these
impressive aspects to the opening of the
story so too did it come with some i
don't want to say negatives but it did
leave me scratching my head a little the
character of iruka is given a lot of
focus in this first chapter i can see
what kishimoto might have been going for
here with him acting as a useful
individual close enough to share
intimate moments with naruto but far
enough away to vent candid frustrations
for us as an audience to understand
within this first chapter he existed as
a vehicle to deliver information to us
about naruto and yet when i finished it
i didn't feel particularly close to
naruto but instead iruka himself due to
the amount of time we spent with him
which might not be a bad thing but
certainly wasn't what i was expecting
nor was it i think what kishimoto was
aiming for furthermore there's an
enormous amount of exposition revealed
in the first chapter alone i would argue
far more than is even necessary to make
that hook at the end of the first
chapter work thankfully however as the
first few chapters drift on by i started
to feel the story catch its stride
through the introduction of two crucial
characters
[Music]
i immediately liked sasuke not only did
i find him well conceived and conveyed
through these introductory chapters but
i also found him to be exactly what this
story needed a rival character a rival
character while having his own goals
that often conflict with the main
character exists primarily to highlight
the significant differences between
himself and the main character in this
case naruto by being a prodigy top of
his class and sought after by sakura
sasuke represents everything that naruto
isn't and what he yearns to be and in
being such also facilitates terrific
contrasts that highlight naruto's
greatest attributes his unflinching
desire to never give up and his roaring
passion to achieve his goal to become
the greatest hokage that ever lived
while a character like sasuke is
nowadays for lack of a better term
cliche i am a firm believer that
oftentimes creative choices become
cliches for a reason because they work
he comes across as dark serious and
single-minded in his one existing goal
to kill a specific individual that
wronged his family in the past which is
great as it not only gives him a want or
desire different from the others but
it's also perfectly emblematic of his
no-nonsense personality and embellishes
his already strong contrast with
naruto's much more lighthearted persona
helping us to better appreciate naruto's
strengths while highlighting his
weaknesses the latter of which
developing into an aspect of the story
that drives so much of who naruto is as
a character in essence i see sasuke as
the perfect foil for naruto in this
story all of which can be observed after
our introduction to another character in
sakura
this one was interesting and well yes in
a fun way not always so going into this
given the time this story was released i
was relieved to see that sakura wasn't
being used for fan service if you like
that sort of thing more power to you but
it's never been for me in the same way i
don't like mindless action i similarly
don't care much for mindless
over-sexualized characters male or
female my favorite aspect of her
character is how effective she can be as
a comic relief oftentimes she's shown
with massively over-exaggerated
expressions of anger and joy which i
thought added some variety to the mix
furthermore from a narrative mechanical
front if we lift the hood on this
metaphorical narrative car we can see
that she's clearly and currently
depicted as less of a character and more
of a mechanism to bolsonaro and sasuke's
respective roles and encounters which
from a utilitarian perspective is not
only fine but exactly what kishimoto was
looking for she is a supporting
character to naruto and sasuke and
without her these two would have very
little reason to interact with each
other at all thus making her
instrumental not only in making sasuke
effective in his role but also by
extension responsible for making the
main character naruto shine she is for
all intents and purposes the catalyst
that makes all the magic happen between
them in the beginning take for example
naruto and sasuke's first ever
interaction in the manga very early on
there's an unrequited love triangle
established between naruto sakura and
sasuke naruto is interested in sakura
sakura hates naruto but loves sasuke and
sasuke loves vengeance but my point is
that without sakura acting as a
connective tissue so to speak between
naruto and sasuke naruto would never
have grown a jealousy for the attention
sasuke is receiving from sakura and
therefore this would never have happened
and what a shame that would be i don't
want to live in a world where this scene
doesn't exist this was the first moment
of the manga that made me burst out
laughing and to be honest mangas don't
do that often for me so she's a great
tool for comedic hijinks too which i
appreciate but to be clear her primary
directive at least in these early
chapters is to facilitate this narrative
sleight of hand time and again
throughout this arc and it works in both
directions however this doesn't excuse
one glaring flaw i've noticed and it's
probably one of my biggest pet peeves
when it comes to character writing she
exists to serve other characters and
little else her existing goals are
selfish certainly but the fact that i
would have zero idea what sort of person
she'd be like if i were to remove naruto
and sasuke from the equation really
serves to highlight my point at this
stage of the story i mean there's a
scene where these three kids get to
introduce themselves to each other a
terrific mechanism for us as an audience
to get to know them better naruto's
intro is quirky and fun with a fiery
ambition clearly present sasukes is
appropriately dark and serious but
sakura's is literally her saying that
she loves sasuke and hates naruto that's
it funnily enough she's about to start
talking about her other hobbies when
kishimoto decides that that's a good
time to cut to kakashi making note that
she seems to care more about love than
ninjutsu which brings me to my main
contention with her as a character her
very presence sort of devalues the
entire social structure and reputation
of the school naruto struggled to gain
acceptance to at this point in the story
she barely says anything other than
wondering where sasuke is or how
annoying naruto can be naruto does have
a large interest in her and interest
that at points in this arc drives him to
make certain decisions but he's still
able to have other interests and driving
forces in his life outside of that his
main motivation is to become the next
hokage and that's awesome absolutely
something i can get behind but if all he
wanted to do was to chase sakura that
would be much less interesting in short
i respect what she offers the story in
terms of quality but as a character i
not only find her quite vapid but i also
found that at times her inclusion tends
to devalue what it is they are trying to
achieve but perhaps it's still early
days and i haven't given her a chance to
fully express who she is as a character
and what she really wants to be fair she
is standing alongside two very well
realized characters and speaking of
contrasts when i picked up volume 2 the
cover brought to my attention something
rather interesting from an artistic
point of view front and center on the
cover we see sakura sasuke and naruto a
fairly standard cover considering the
contents of this volume concerned them
specifically however in my hunter hunter
review i eventually pointed out what
made gone and kilauea were thoughtfully
designed characters from an artistic
point of view they acted as a great
inversion of colors in the manga when
compared to each other but kishimoto
takes that to the next level with these
three to complement naruto's upbeat and
fiery personality he's given him bright
vibrant orange and yellows everywhere
for sasuke his dark and more stoic
personality lends better to darker tones
but what makes him particularly
wonderful is only seen in the full color
i mentioned that sasuke is a wonderful
rival character because he effectively
contrasts and complements naruto's
personality amplifying his effect well
if we look at a color wheel we can quite
clearly see what the opposite or color
complement to orange is it's blue sasuke
dons a wonderfully dark blue getup
communicating his darker sensibilities
and highlighting what he represents to
the main character naruto a contrast but
my friends that's not where this ends i
mentioned before that sakura is sort of
the connective tissue that brings these
two into contact in many ways she acts
as the midpoint between the two of them
naturally she's going to be colored red
to represent her main driving motivation
love and the word sakura directly
translated means cherry blossom so pink
is a natural inclusion here too but
one look at the color wheel again and
you'll notice that pink and red are
exactly halfway between orange and blue
in other words she is right in the
middle between
sasuke and naruto i love stuff like this
well done kishimoto
school's back and that means many hours
of painful studying for many of you i
may be long past school but all this
narrative analysis requires a lot of
reading and with my hectic schedule it
sure is nice to do things on the go
here's how my recons helped me and maybe
you'll find they'll help you too when
i'm out and walking my dogs or even
laying in bed at night i'll often have
academic books playing in my ears and my
recons provide excellent comfort thanks
to the gel tips that let you find the
perfect match for your ear size the
built-in mic is also great for letting
me take voice notes whenever an idea
comes to mind or i hear something that i
absolutely
have to remember crystal clear high
quality stuff all this in a stunning
improved rubber oil finish that's super
smooth to the touch it looks and feels
premium and the fact that it's all at
half the price of other brands is pretty
insane i've spoken about the battery
life many times before but it really
cannot be overstated just how good it is
8 hours of constant playtime or a
general 32 hour battery life they last
so unbelievably long guys the comfort of
knowing that they'll be good to go when
you need them is seriously invaluable so
if you think these will make your
studying life as easy as they've made
mine click the link in the description
box or go to buy raycon dot com slash
not mark to get 15 off your raikon
purchase with a 45 45-day money-back
guarantee if you're not happy with them
you've honestly got nothing to lose
[Music]
truth be told by the time i reached
chapter 8 i was a little tired of the
current format this first third of the
arc while it did have elements i enjoyed
like the schooling with kakashi and the
various challenges he presents them with
i still felt like the narrative of
naruto and most importantly what people
liked and loved about it wasn't
translating clearly for me school is
usually a surefire way to create
instances of hijinks and conflict but
truth be told there wasn't a lot of
focus given to it the best part was the
bent-a-box challenge seeing sasuke work
his magic and show how much better he is
than the rest was exactly the
reassurance i needed to confidently
press onward into the second third and
fourth volumes and thank god i did
i believe chapter 9 and 10 were where i
went from being undecided about this
story to sincerely enjoying the
experience when reading and reviewing
manga became my job i felt grateful of
course but also concerned as now a hobby
my one time retreat suddenly became my
job and oftentimes in this line of work
i found psyching myself up to read a
particular volume of manga to be
difficult and with the first few
chapters of naruto passing one after the
other i felt as though i might be facing
another wall of manga i simply have to
get through but nothing could be further
from the truth with this
[Music]
chapter 9 is a glorious chapter that
while exposition heavy also carries with
it a palpable and natural rising tension
i've often said in the past that
pressure more so than conflict gives the
audience a chance to see who the
characters they're following really are
and to this chapter's credit it delivers
just the right amount of exposition to
build up to two payoffs in both this
chapter and the next something that's
very important to me as a reviewer is
that i connect with on some level what
the author is trying to say and nowhere
is this more crucial than with the main
character having come to know and loved
the likes of goku luffy the jojo's and
numerous other wonderful characters over
the span of my life
i was deeply concerned particularly
after the rocky start that i wouldn't
connect with naruto but
i think i see more of myself in this
little character than any of the others
while i love the simplicity and grit of
goku and the kind but tenacious edge to
luffy there's something about naruto
that defines his character that i find
infectious
doubt
he will work his hands to the bone walk
the soles off his shoes and work until
he collapses to make up for what he
perceives to be defects or flaws in his
own approach he recognizes that he's not
the most intelligent or the most
talented and we're shown as much thanks
to the character of sasuke and so being
faced with that reality he only knows
how to put his shoulder down and push
himself he has aspirations and he wants
to prove to himself that he's more than
what everyone thought he was and in
chapter 9 i learned this about him
having been almost killed freezing at
the first sign of real danger he's
forced to contend with the fact that
sasuke was ready and he wasn't and that
maybe
just maybe
those naysayers from his village
were right and seeing that frustration
bubble beneath the surface of his
expression was amazing to sit and read
through particularly because
it readied us for what was to come
one final thing i really enjoyed
concerning naruto as a character in
these chapters was how kishimoto decided
to splice in the exposition to influence
how we might feel about naruto as a
character after stabbing his own hand in
frustration and determination not to
become a burden to slow people down
kakashi notices how fast he's healing
from the beginning the nine-tailed fox
spirit trapped inside naruto has been a
source of all his longing and suffering
he's been made practically a pariah
since that fateful day by everyone in
his community and now kishimoto wants us
to believe that the only thing that
makes naruto special is his nine-tailed
fox spirit if he does anything bad then
that's to be expected he has the fox
spirit after all and if he does anything
good now then it too can be chalked down
to that very spirit he's infused with
but in this chapter when faced by the
mounting pressures around him instead of
freezing like he did last time he looks
to his hand
as a reminder
plants his feet and stands up to someone
that just took out his teacher an
impressive elite level ninja i don't
know what the prevailing narrative
concerning naruto is online what
people's feelings are towards him but
what impresses me about his character
isn't the ability he was able to bring
out just in time to save the day but
it's the bravery and determination he
showed in the face of a situation we
know he was scared to tackle it wasn't
the action that preceded it it was the
decision to take that action in the
first place and all of this was helped
enormously by the artwork it should go
without saying at this point that these
chapters are filled with wonderful
action of numerous varieties within
which i finally felt as though i was
starting to understand kishimoto's
rhythm as a layout artist and that
rhythm being when he's at his best he
catches you off guard he sets something
up only for it to be observed by the
elite ninjas and for them to reverse it
on us again and again and again it's a
wonderfully quirky style of paneling
that infuses wonderfully with the very
concept and theme of the story being
told
i've said this before but i love these
types of visually interesting and
conceptually simple training exercises
or challenges for characters stuff like
snake way moving a boulder climbing a
tower or in this case climbing a tree
climbing the tree using chakra is a
really fun and visually interesting idea
for the premise of a chapter but what i
really liked about it was how as soon as
kakashi mentioned this element to the
chakras as something that if one can
master then nothing is beyond them in
terms of jutsu a panel is dedicated
specifically to show us naruto's
expression and it says everything i can
tell that to him to have that question
answered would mean a lot the exercise
in action is a nice bolstering of what i
mentioned earlier about sakura where
sasuke exerted too much force and naruto
too little sakura hit the sweet spot
right in the middle and climbed the tree
without the use of her arms in addition
to this being a nice visual and
narrative reminder of what she
represents to the two characters in
question it's honestly nice to see her
exceed in her own unique way ahead of
the other two for a change that is until
one page later workakashi says that the
pools of untapped chakra concealed
within naruto and sasuke make sakuras
look like nothing
that's disappointing concerning sakura
there is one scene i really enjoyed her
participation in however with sakura
having already completed the challenge
climbing their respective trees became a
head-to-head challenge with sasuke miles
ahead of naruto through this obviously
it's wonderful to see him slowly catch
up again not necessarily because he's
more talented or a prodigy like sasuke
is but because he was willing to ask for
help and take the advice of someone like
sakura that was successful before him
something sasuke never thought to do
it's a small moment but it once again
made use of the two supporting
characters in a clever way to amplify
the desired effect of the main character
naruto
in the beginning of this video i was
lukewarm on this story i felt as though
it was a little unfocused or
unconventional which made it difficult
to latch onto and fully enjoy for me
however slowly chapter by chapter scene
by scene as we advanced farther and
farther into this story i grew a
fondness for this world and its
characters unlike stories i've covered
before naruto was different for one
reason right from the get-go with hunter
hunter it was clear to me it was a dark
dramatic character-driven story first
and foremost the same can be said for
one piece with its strong focus on world
building perhaps more so than any other
story i've read luffy's adventure hinges
on its world feeling alive as well as
its numerous colorful characters attack
on titan on the other hand was driven by
its premise early on and dragon ball by
its comedy and action but when it came
to naruto i was left undecided for quite
some time i couldn't figure out what it
was that made it so special to so many
people it had some terrific action
endearing comedy an interesting world
and as i've outlined already some nicely
realized characters in the likes of
naruto sasuke kakashi and even sakura to
some extent however at no point did i
feel like it was balanced to favor any
one area of those over the other that
was until i reached the final encounter
of this arc
when it came to the closing moments of
this arc within the final chaotic battle
pitting the likes of sasuke and haku
against each other and kakashi and
sabuza too it felt as though i finally
began to understand what it was that
naruto was especially focused on and i
have to say
it feels rather unique to naruto
something i've mentioned a number of
times in this video has been that of who
i think naruto is and one of the many
reasons why this scene depicting naruto
lost in anger strikes a chord with me is
that it once again draws a distinction
between who people think he is and who
he actually is it feels ominous dark
coupled that with kakashi making mention
that he can't feel naruto's energy and
you have for yourself something that
more closely resembles a possession than
a convenient chosen one-type power-up
moment erupting forth from naruto not
because he summoned it but because he
specifically didn't losing control of
who he is for a split second allowing
that demonic spirit coiled within him to
spring forth with savage and reckless
intent and what stops him in his tracks
[Music]
the second that power vanishes is the
moment naruto regains his sense of self
strangely what i thought this scene
shared some commonalities with was
avatar the last airbender within the
first few episodes aang's confronted
with the horror that took place in his
absence once he arrives back at his air
temple faced with this shock and
disarray he loses himself to the avatar
state thankfully brought back before he
could hurt anyone by the loving embrace
of katara in naruto similar to avatar
it's being made evident that the fox
spirit inside naruto isn't him
necessarily and instead what makes
naruto who he is similar to aang was his
ability to control himself before he
hurt someone he cared about and this
sentiment of constantly wanting to try
to never give up and to control whatever
you can makes itself known at numerous
wonderful instances during the story
none perhaps more powerful than through
inari's flashbacks naruto not only feels
an obligation to help people but
particularly those that he sees himself
in perhaps because he's a good person
but also perhaps these lost toys more so
because he empathizes with their
situation specifically with haku and
inari acting as two sides of that naruto
coin in a sense inari thankfully had
someone in naruto to instill a positive
outlook on his situation leading to his
eventual and fantastic save at the end
but on the other hand we have someone
like haku a character with an outlook so
disastrously unfortunate and tragic that
it's almost difficult to accept that he
has so much in common with our main
character naruto in the first place with
his untimely and frankly harrowing end
coming moments after this heart to heart
and through this horribly sad end to a
fantastic battle something inside my
head clicked i mentioned towards the
beginning of the story that i found the
start somewhat rough around the edges
unfocused and ill-defined however now
having completed the first arc and
having gotten a taste of what this story
really is all about this story naruto
feels perfect as a story penned by
masashi kishimoto at the beginning of
the very first volume i picked up
kishimoto wrote a short paragraph
thanking us for our support of his dream
overjoyed he wrote that this was the
happiest moment of his life unlike akira
toriyama someone he admired and looked
up to kishimoto's path to success wasn't
as straightforward nothing seemed to
come easy to him time and again he'd
face rejection after rejection at every
corner all in a desperate attempt to
achieve his dream of one day breaking
into the manga industry it's not
difficult to see the parallels he's
drawn between his personal experiences
and the beginning of naruto's story the
journey of a young unwanted orphan child
tenaciously and earnestly pursuing his
dreams despite his detractors and in no
more fitting or poetical fashion
together both kishimoto and naruto help
each other to achieve their respective
dreams speaking as a creative myself one
of the biggest difficulties in my
professional life has been my family's
initial disapproval of my vocation but
at no point could i ever see myself
doing anything other than this i love my
job exhausting and stressful as it may
be at times i love this and i think
that's why i tend to fall in love with
characters that have a strong sense of
self above all else characters like
luffy someone that no matter what it
takes will in an unflinching fashion
march onward towards his goal it's
inevitable he will be the pirate king or
goku someone i found a lot of comfort in
as a kid growing up to him nothing ever
seemed insurmountable he was never
scared and to this day the effect this
moment has had on me can be felt naruto
however isn't like either of these two
he's me
you
us he's that kid that has a chip on his
shoulder something to prove someone that
doesn't know for certain if he will
achieve his dreams but god damn it he's
gonna push himself until he cannot push
himself any further it is for that
reason among so many others i can't help
but root for naruto when he fights for
his dreams and it's why i've developed a
special fondness for kishimoto's story
it's still no dragon ball hunter hunter
jojo and certainly not a one piece but
it doesn't have to be it's naruto it's
musashi kishimoto pouring his heart out
and it's created something that at least
to me feels entirely different it's
something that was unbelievably special
to one person in the beginning and
became special to millions around the
world today and i think finally i
understand that feeling and it's only
the beginning i can't wait to see where
this earnest endearing and emotional
adventure will lead me but until then
i've been told not mark i'll see you all
next week
and thank you so much for watching
[Music]
motivate your anger to make them more
realized club in the mountain
never coming down breaking to the
contents never falling down
[Music]